we are joined by Mark Mazzetti he is the
Washington investigative editor at the
New York Times and he is in our
Washington bureau mark good morning
morning mark the this this the the
scandal of the memo if there is a
scandal focuses on the warrant to
surveil Carter page and central in the
back and forth here is whether or not
the FBI failed to disclose partisan
connections that Christopher Steele may
have had he of course is the author of
that dossier what do we know about what
the FBI disclosed or did not disclose
about partisan affiliations you're right
that's the central issue boiled
everything down and it gets to this
question of did the FBI tell the court
that Christopher Steele's information
was politically motivated that he was
being paid for by Democrats and that
issue is still in dispute the memo that
Nunez released yesterday said the court
was never told of any political
affiliation steel had the Democrats were
pushing back and say that's wrong he
what the court was told so so even after
all of this build up this question still
is unresolved and will still be part of
the battleground going forward mark
there is a democratic memo in effect a
rebuttal to this will we see this memo
Nunez said yesterday that they will put
out the Democratic memo it has to go
through a de classification process I
don't know when that's going to be but
he's saying that that that they will put
it out and and again this is going to
continue to feed the dispute you would
have thought that this issue would have
at least been resolved the facts behind
it would have been resolved by the time
the memo came out but but in fact it
actually just created even more
controversy and that's something that
the Democrats are going to continue to
push back on because it's a central
issue mark a lot of folks are saying the
real bombshell in this report is that it
inadvertently confirms that the source
of the FBI's investigation was not
Carter page but the other former chompin
foreign policy adviser George
papadopolis that's right
in December the Times reported that put
the Popat
appleís information information he had
been given to an Australian diplomat
during a night of heavy drinking in
London in 2016
actually was really the trigger for the
FBI's investigation which began in July
2016 it was not Carter Paige
it was Papadopoulos and a couple other
elements the Nunez memo confirms that
says that Carter page the FISA warrant
for Carter page actually came later a
couple months after that so it was
actually something that confirmed and
kind of undercut the argument that
Republicans had been making that Carter
page was central to this whole thing
well I did yeah go ahead mark now one
other point is that it was a little
puzzling that the Republicans decided to
make Carter page part of this big
campaign after the White House had spent
a year distancing themselves from Carter
page the Papadopoulos piece is
meaningful right because the idea that
somehow the Carter page piece of this is
going to discredit the Muller and Vega
investigation well if George papadopolis
is actually the true source doesn't it
suggest that the investigation itself is
legitimate no matter what is the case
with Carter page right so if you look at
what happened yesterday it revealed that
the FBI's investigation which Muller has
now taken over was begun long before
Carter page entered the picture and this
FISA warrant was used remember that this
is kind of a proxy battle the memo is a
proxy battle for the Muller
investigation to discredit the Muller
investigation and what we sort of saw
yesterday was that it didn't really do
that it didn't discredit the Muller
probe because we learned that the Muller
the FBI investigation which Muller took
over had begun long before Carter page
really entered the picture as a critical
target in this all right mark Mazzetti
thank you very much for being with us
this morning thank you